the worst employee is a good employee a
bad employee is fine because you fire
that person right away a great employee
is phenomenal you want to keep them and
cherish them they're fantastic
but a good employee you never sort of
fire them but they never lead you to the
next level they just keep their job
they're sort of too good to be fired but
they're not good enough you're never
gonna do great so I always say the worst
employee isn't a bad employee it's just
a good or average employee Gary player
the great golfer he was a little guy
very little but he worked really hard
and he had a great statement but he'd go
the harder I work the luckier I get and
he wins the US Open you have all these
big handsome guys these big giant guys
and they're hitting the ball a mile and
you have Gary Player and Gary Player
would win the open hid win the Masters
hid win this it went that in the US Open
he had a 5-iron to one foot from the
Hall and he ended up getting a birdie
and wins the US Open right and he came
off to green oh I know I've heard the
statement before but I heard it from him
in a meaningful way they said what do
you think Gary what is it he said all I
know is I've been working very hard and
the harder I work the luckier I get I
thought it was an amazing statement you
just watched two amazing clips from
Donald Trump take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how to
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]